on Friday Taiwanese president sighing
when landed in one of the few countries
in Latin America to still support her in
a diplomatic battle with China for
influence
rarely can the small impoverished nation
of Guatemala been so important to a
leader on the other side of the world
I am convinced that the union and
cooperation between Democratic Partners
will increase our resilience allowing us
to solve together any kind of challenges
that we might face later in time
president Giamatti was Keen to assure
her that this would be so Guatemala
continuing to recognize Taiwan as China
looks to cut off International support
to the small self-governing island that
it says is part of its territory
for Guatemala this is a significant
visit to renew and reaffirm the full
support of Taiwan reiterating the
recognition of Taiwan as an independent
nation and the only and true China that
support does not come for free Taiwan
has already plowed money into Guatemala
and is expected to continue to do so to
maintain its loyalty a loyalty which
symbolically at least is vital Taiwan
now has only 13 official diplomatic
Partners worldwide and in Latin America
it's losing ground
just days before the visit Honduras
broke with it in favor of China
Nicaragua El Salvador the Dominican
Republic Panama and Costa Rica had
already made the switch allies fooling
like dominoes as China comes cooling
with the Hefty checkbook looking not
just to cut off Taiwan but to compete
with the US in its traditional sphere of
influence in Central America now only
Guatemala and Belize which Psy will also
visit this weekend remain with Taiwan
[Music]
said during the visit that the
relationship here was Unbreakable
strong words that will be tested as
China and its money continue to come
calling
John Holman Al Jazeera